[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director here at long aisle
thank you all for coming tonight tonight
is one of our partner events with the SF
Asia Society were super excited to have
a speaker all the way from the other the
other other hemisphere that we sometimes
bring people from Europe but it's rare
that we able to bring people from Asia
and so we're very excited for that and
get this perspective and for tonight's
long service many of you may know we do
what's called the long short a short
film that it's in play in some way both
Tiny's in with the evenings theme as
well as exemplifies long-term thinking
and tonight's is I think an interesting
one in that we're gonna be hearing about
many interventions that happen at
museums and this is I think one of the
more let's say you know in some ways
kind of disrupting ones of a of a museum
and so enjoy
I was born in Chicago raised in Memphis
Tennessee didn't start dance until I was
like 11 years old the dance style I do
the dance style that started with
Memphis underground rap music and that
music the way it was produced gave us a
certain balance when I was around 16
years old I got into ballet we made a
deal with this artistic director we
would teach hip-hop and then they would
teach us in ballet that's how it
happened that's performing artists and
as dancers you see everything is our
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
do any of that I disturb Bram from water
now Foundation reminder that the
question cards which we hope you'll use
get to the stage best and have the more
impact on the discourse if they are
extremely legible and extremely short
because I'm reading them in a sort of
conflicted situation here in Alexander
Rose who's going through them is reading
them in the dark bear that in mind we've
got a few salt talks about the east and
the west or the west and the rest why
the West rules for now for now from
historian from Stanford Ian Morris of in
thanks to society
we had you show them up abounding
sitting that's the West lost it again
the rest save it so there's a dialogue
going on and here in San Francisco and
here with something that calls itself
the long now we want to be part of that
art is a big part of it and there's
shifts going on one of the things I
learned from our speaker before up in
the green room where this up for quite a
while now whether the place where you
bought art was in New York and the
second major source of buying art was
London that's no longer true now the
second major place to go to buy art is
Hong Kong so there's something going on
and our speaker
Suhani and Raphael is in the thick of it
that she's the director of a brand new
museum that is going to be a major focal
point for all of that please welcome
honey
thank you very much
and it really is a privilege and honor
to be here to introduce to you our new
museum m+ in Hong Kong
and for those of you who don't know it I
know this is the West Kowloon site that
is the museum that I'm going to be
talking about and throughout the talk
I'm going to make use of our collection
firstly and importantly to give you a
sense of what this collection looks like
its form its shape to illustrate how we
are looking at the world and making our
stories from the works by artists
architects designers and filmmakers the
collection also acts as a prompt for
ideas and a lens through which we can
think about the context in which this
museum is coming into being the
collections date from the mid 20th
century and on into the future and our
location in Hong Kong shapes that
collection its texture structure and
content with the roots growing in with
the roots and the energy of that word
growing out of the rich visual culture
of Hong Kong first and then Asia and
beyond so what does Hong Kong look like
when seen through some of the works in
the N+ collection and I want to begin my
talk tonight looking at a quick look at
the work of Hong Kong artists I enjoy
working in the medium of ink hearth
works full of controlled energy now ink
even in its contemporary expression
draws on formal East Asian and Chinese
forms where ink has a long history of
landscape painting and
big Rafi the innovation of contemporary
Inc
was in the development of a unique
abstract language and in the mid 20th
century Hong Kong art has played a key
role in this development including
hiring Joe in this painting
Irene's abstract I offers a perfect
emblem through which to enter into the M
plus collection journey from Hong Kong
and beyond the first of these two slides
is by Holly Lee whose work the great
pattern show is one of the most
recognizable of her works where
portraiture is central to her practice
and is manipulated the model here is an
amalgamation of queen elizabeth ii and a
miss hong kong beauty pageant winner
predominantly presented prominently in
front of a Qing Court
painting depicting an equestrian event
in the ching long reign by giuseppe cast
a leone and italian jesuit missionary in
China between seventeen fifteen and
seventeen sixty the series from which
this great potential is drawn from
consists of twelve conceptual
photographs created between 1994 and
2000 and muses on the past and future of
Hong Kong around the time of the
transfer of sovereignty in 1997 together
with me - the subject being an image of
a fire hydrant you know a residue of the
Great British Empire it is a print and
the artist has looked at the graffiti
and its calligraphy made a decade prior
to Lee these two works together gives
one a sense of the confluence of
histories that touch on this period of
intense change
Gregg Girard photographs Hong Kong and
it's the Hong Kong we known for its
dense urban landscape a vertical
crowded narrow city streets this
quintessential image of kowloon walled
city captures all that and more
the king of Kowloon who used the streets
walls posters footpaths doorways as his
canvas covering them with his idea
granite calligraphic symbols layers upon
layers of mark making much of it king of
of king of King of Kowloon's work now
exists as documentary images made by
others and this is by another mountain
man who is the architect designer and
artist Stanley wrong now Hong Kong
wouldn't be Hong Kong without Cantopop
which is an abbreviation for Cantonese
pop and this album cover was designed by
Alan Chan for the Kanto pop diva Anita
Mui a symbol of the popular forms
highest glories with a fan base and live
constant practice that reaches mainland
China Taiwan Singapore Malaysia South
Korea and Japan and formed a highly
influential base for song performance
and soundtrack for the great era of Hong
Kong film culture the plastic watermelon
bomb ball is attributed to the engineer
turned industrialist Chang Chen who
developed this 2 color extrusion blow
molding process that yields the balls
now familiar ubiquitous pattern all over
Hong Kong Jiang is said to have been
inspired by the Yangtze River and its
tributary the jangling whose coloured
the colors always remained distinct in
its confluence from the iconic 70s
headquarters in San pokum star
industrial now produces over 600 items
these rare products known for their
quality durability affordability
continued to be sold locally and
nationally and part of Radiesse success
comes from the company's ability to
adapt product lines to the needs of the
times and for different markets
particularly markets in the developing
countries
so not only are ready products
ubiquitous in Hong Kong many of their
designs are now recognized as iconic
examples of non-canonical design that
represent Hong Kong's
vernacular culture now as the tram is
for central San Francisco so is the red
taxi to Hong Kong and this playful
sculpture of a lopsided and skewered
taxi inevitably draws the audience to
think about perspective placed in public
locations in Hong Kong and Guangzhou
such as taxi queues parking lots in the
waterfront ami Chung sculpture
challenged public perception of what is
real another of how Holly's holidays
work Bohemia 1997 chooses to engage with
the stylized bauhinia flower which is
the emblem that appears on the flags and
official CEOs of the Hong Kong Special
Administrative Region as well as various
souvenir products that were available at
the time continuing to youth to use a
distinct photographic language and oil
painting like cracks that she has been
developing this image of the Bao hanya
flower is set against the typical Hong
Kong skyline commonly depicted in
stamped sand postcards made in the year
of Hong Kong's handover which marks the
agreement of the one country two
systems' Vik Muniz Vik Muniz as postcard
captures Hong Kong a city that is still
one of the world's leading international
financials
with a free-market economy now these
fine line drawings by Wilson share riff
on the iconic skyscrapers of Hong Kong
skyline and the HSBC building and the
Bank of China are those very
institutions that are the engines of the
city
Michael Wolf's astonishing photographic
series and in these we see Hong Kong's
vertical towers that rise in clusters
across the city and point to one of the
most populated and dense city escapes in
the world and that is his inspiration
with the population of seven and a half
million in 2019 the city's real estate
market that deals in the most expensive
housing in the world produces a living
environment that forces families to live
in this intense proximity these are the
interiors of those very same towers that
wolf has now entered if this is a
snapshot that can capture some of the
visual vocabulary of Hong Kong Asia
forms the structural base in which M
plus operates in July this year McKinsey
Global Institute published a fascinating
paper titled Asia's future is now now
the opening paragraph of the paper reads
for years Western observers and media
have been talking about the rise of Asia
in terms of its massive future potential
but the time has come for the rest of
the world to update its thinking because
the future arrived faster than expected
one of the most dramatic developments of
the past 30 years has been Asia's
soaring consumption and its integration
into
flaws of trade capital talent and
innovation in the decades ahead
Asia's economies will go from
participating in these flows to
determining their shape and direction
indeed in many areas from the internet
to trade and luxury goods they already
are the question now is no longer how
quickly Asia will rise but how
Asia will lead a sure is on track to top
50% of global GDP by 2040 by which time
it will drive 40 percent of the world's
consumption thus representing a real
shift in the world's economic center of
gravity consumption is now local instead
of being solely exported to the West
which means less reliance on imports
with more than half of the goods being
traded now being within the asia-pacific
region it is an intra regional exchange
now this is a still from a video work
titled 75 watts and the london-based
artist designers revitalign and tour van
Balan worked with the choreographer
Alexandre Whitely to design a product
whose only function is to choreograph
its own manufacture produced in
zhongshan guangdong province by assembly
line workers who had been specifically
trained to perform Whiteley's
choreography the object of this work
reflects on mass production and the role
of scientific management in the
mechanization and in this case it's the
human body in the name of efficiency
after studying and working in Japan
years vote Rania viewed he's returned to
Vietnam to practice architecture as both
an opportunity and a responsibility the
wind and water bar was Nia's first
project built purely out of bamboo and
he chose this material for its low cost
ecological value its strengths and its
local mass it exemplifies the
environmental and social agenda driving
his work which looks to reconnect human
built forms with nature and greenery the
sketches and model reveal how each
bamboo structural unit is constructed
and bundled to form the dome structure
in a way that maximizes the flexibility
and strength of the mean of the material
Gengo GU sample room perfect a literal
example of the known manufacturing base
of China the problem the Prophet the
proliferation that is made in China but
with this production not only has the
economic process being rapid so has
urbanization and the growth of a huge
middle class with a substantial
disposable income base this urbanization
has fuelled an economic growth that has
opened doors to education health and
wealth in 1983 are then relatively
unknown zaha hadid won the competition
to design a leisure Club at of Hong
Kong's peak one of her competition
proposal images is pictured here and the
brief called for in quotation an
extremely luxurious residential club and
of course that would provide dramatic
views from its site on the peak Hadid
proble had its proposed scheme was
roughly divided into four stacks and
sharp
layers with a void in the middle in the
middle housing the club facilities the
result provided a formal an
architectural vocabulary that was
jarring for its time beating out 500
other entries and earning praise from
the jury while the scheme remained
unbuilt
it helped cement the Iraq the Iraqi born
london-based
architects reputation at the forefront
of her discipline how did continue to
defy the limits of possibility in her
work through an abashed formal
experimentation to propose an entirely
new language for architecture the
digital internet and online world is a
given in Asia today this accounts for
half which is 2.2 billion of the world's
Internet use users with China and India
accounting for 1/3 of this use between
them the m+ collections reflect on the
highly innovative use and application of
digital tools within the spheres of
design in architecture as well as online
artists projects young hey Chang Heavy
Industries a South Korean based artist
Jo who pioneered making out with the web
being their sole platform empire m+
acquired their entire catalogue of works
including works that they are yet to
make in the future which they will
continue to add to our collection
through a program of gifting Isaac
Julien's beautiful multi-channel
immersive digital installation 10,000
waves
drew its inspiration from this Millia an
activity but cited his four
happiness in an idyllic mythic Eastasia
while also using digital technologies to
realize is dreamlike sequences what is
real what is simulacrum is opaque now I
hope with this first suite of works I
have set the scene these are these
opening collection images coupled with
factual analytics of the wider context
of the region gives you a perspective on
what I'm are now about to share in this
rare example of a collectible work by
the king of Kowloon we see a fragment of
West Kowloon the site on which in class
is being constructed in 1991 that is
what the site looked like in 2017 that
is what it looks like now so the West
Kowloon district was built on this
parcel of reclaimed land 40 hectares on
which the ambition of the district was
to build 17 cultural institutions but by
2005 seven of them will be realized this
is an aerial view of that site with the
M + construction in in the middle of it
there so what does this site look like
this is a master plan that was devised
by Sir Norman Foster
and Norman Foster but principal of the
foster master plan was that the West
Kowloon would be pedestrian and all of
the transport infrastructure would be in
the basement these are the cultural
facilities and you can see 23 hectares
of open space
subway Metro access ferries the
airport's connectivity a central part of
any cultural district and the
connectivity in West Kowloon is
extraordinary the airport on which M
plus is in minutes to the West Kowloon
station and the airport expressway the
airport reaches half the world's
population in five hours flying time and
we already have 74 million people
arriving into Hong Kong every year 2018
there is a major Express rail link into
mainland China and currently 50,000
people are dropping in a month the
capacity of that rail link is a hundred
thousand a day the cruise terminal 80
million people come every year so what
does the financials look like for the
museum always a good question and in the
public domain the background for the
financial arrangements are that twenty
one point six billion Hong Kong which is
approximately 2.8 billion u.s. dollars
was given over by the Hong Kong
government directly to the West Kowloon
district authority that runs this whole
project at the time in 2008 it it was
understood that the retail and dining
and entertainment would provide a steady
source of income for the recurrent needs
of cultural institutions very clearly at
the time there was not well there was no
knowledge about what cultural
institutions actually cost around those
of us in the audience who work there
know this the public infrastructure work
would be supported through government
and that is fundamentally the integrated
basement as as you as I said before all
of the transport infrastructure sits in
the basement but this is a very very
complex
engineering because we're farber
basically in the sea nice idea but very
expensive to realize by 2017 it was very
clear that this financial arrangement
was not going to be possible to continue
so a new enhanced financial arrangement
was announced West Kowloon cultural
district authority will be granted the
development rights so a third of that 40
hectares is there to develop commercial
endeavor hotels offices residential and
so on and that development will be done
through an hor for the hotels the rest
offices in Brazil through a
build-operate-transfer arrangement and
this shared rental from the facilities
would drive income now this is one of
the most valuable parcels of land in the
world is this this 40 hectares and it's
a very interesting business model for
developing cultural infrastructure and
we are only just beginning this project
I have a short video to play to you on
what in place looks like now
[Music]
any class is a new museum of visual
culture in Hong Kong currently under
construction ready for the public within
a year and a half this is an
extraordinary opportunity a piece of
cultural infrastructure like no other in
the world
[Music]
we've reached the top floor of the top
of the building it's an important first
step towards that final opening push and
that gives us the opportunity really to
make a change from being a construction
project to a development and delivery
project
[Music]
funny by golly my comic campaign check
because I am coveting semi psychotic in
don't I see comical iike psychic engine
park iko iko facial yoga lady thing we
could not decide on the name of the
museum then we said a museum plus which
is so original
and today we are talking in this
beautiful weather and we look very much
forward to the opening and the
Australian Museum in the asia-pacific
but this is the back yeah okay
okay so the ghetto blanket off on
occasion Amma showing your dog Alaric
Authority so you carry on 2000 Lee
jong-seok is a concealer you see how is
a tire something hi plan or they start
off so subset pendulous or home care
economist
all comes if I enjoy it a lot I like how
it's flying L see a birthday candle
it's always good to see the real spaces
because we've been looking at the floor
for all of five years if I get anything
we've got a lot of work to do
since recessive phenotype from the other
or he comically Tom Savini daily the
order of mega cool guy
you are mistaken we are picking a
hypothesis Erica
[Music]
am I taking you home one more unity on
Kara come with a serum
we'll do a taxi what is like tight tight
ass
[Music]
always integrate and on and on I see or
join our high frequency high powers it
the N plus the SAP building so special
because the facade I'm not typical
material like the one we use in Hong
Kong normally is aluminium and glass our
facade is a PCAST unit with a ceramic
tile in a modular system and we also
serve as a Sun Shade to the office tower
whereas the podium facade is enclosed
designed to provide an optimum and mind
for the gallery
the building that was developed actually
became in two parts the main building
with Giridhar and the conservation
storage facility it is a building that
will basically have the collection when
he's not on display it's also combined
with the conservation laboratories which
are the areas where conservators where
the doctors of the art would be actually
taking care of physical care of the
object
this location on West Kowloon facing
Hong Kong Island is the postcard view of
Hong Kong so for us to be making a
museum on this side brings a whole other
level of understanding about what Hong
Kong is now delivering to the world and
[Music]
so what are we delivering a new museum
dedicated to collecting exhibiting and
interpreting visual culture of the 20th
and 21st centuries and we are indeed
building one of the largest museums of
modern and contemporary visual culture
it has it is sixty-five thousand square
meters of museum space with 17,000
square meters of galleries and display
space 18 levels 33 galleries 3 cinemas
and a media thing our location is
extremely important the local and the
international the cosmopolitan spirit of
Hong Kong that's the context on which
this museum is being developed for for
Asia's 21st century we're a global
museum and our context in Asia shapes
our work and our voice is distinctive
and it reflects the uniqueness of our
time and place and why is in plus
relevant it's very important to say that
an M plus is a museum that looks out at
the world from its base in Hong Kong and
it is a place where we can learn about
who we are how we see the world how we
see ourselves and how ideas are shared
and our voice it's very important for a
museum to have a voice we will be
distinctive knowledgeable and accessible
and of course everything we do is more
than a building it is an amplification
of the relationship between our content
and audiences but our building our
building is part of
collection a collection that embraces
architecture we have an incredible
building designed by the Swiss
architects Hertzog and murren and in
their inimitable way what is looks like
a very simple structure has a complex
internal presence and of course as you
heard from the construction workers fair
faced concrete art concrete as they call
it is a very much part of HTM language
we have very traditional white cube
museum spaces as well as one suite of
three galleries that pay homage to East
Asian architecture bamboo lined
galleries now the C collection our
founding m+ collection was a major gift
of over 1500 works by early seek the
eminent collector and was made in 2012
this collection were of work spans the
70s 1970s the 1980's the 1990s and the
2000s Olli was among the very first
launch I knees to enter mainland China
in the 70s to establish a formal
business partnership with Chinese count
counterparts working at that time for
the Swiss company Schindler group to
return later to become to become the
Swiss ambassador to China North Korea
and Mongolia in 1995 and he currently
serves on the board of the China
Development Bank his passion for
contemporary Chinese art and collecting
began primarily as a means of getting to
understand culture in which he was now
living and
King however he realized early on while
he was mixing with artists visiting
Studios and seeing exhibitions as they
unfolded over these four seminal decades
that there were no institutions in China
that was collecting this material so he
decided then to focus his collection
development to be a systematic and
researched exercise one that he knew
would be the kind of collection and
National Museum should have been making
he does began built an extensive and
highly significant and coherent
collection of contemporary Chinese art
that has established the core collection
for Empress what is that collection
looked like now after seven years of
work six thousand three hundred odd
items twenty percent of which are by
Hong Kong makers and thirty five
thousand-plus
archives primarily are architecture and
design collections and that you what you
see is a global spread of that
collection but we also let's look at
some of the other highlights Shangguan
Jie who was Hong Kong born us art as
part of the East Village art scene in
New York in the 80s and in this still
which is part of that larger series that
he made God east-meets-west
his project was to photograph himself
amongst famous world monuments and
tourist sites the way of in scribing
himself onto the world a major
undertaking by this British artist whose
epic work Asian fields consists of over
a hundred and eighty thousand clay
figures that anthony gormley made during
a number of workshops that he undertook
in Guangdong province now as much as
being a social project
is also a work about public sculpture
and questioning authorship and this work
is an example of how we collect major
global artists from for Hong Kong it is
the intersection of the international
into Asia that drives the primary
collection interest
similarly Frank Lloyd Wright's work in
Japan
designing furniture for the Imperial
Hotel even bombed Guangzhou Opera House
and the Kermit a sushi bar now you might
have gathered that we are
cross-disciplinary
design and architecture sits very much
in the heart of the collection as does
moving image and visual art this
cross-disciplinary approach brings a
unique voice to the institution of the
scale for Asia and key individuals such
as Cora Mata and acquiring the entire
sushi bar place as a focal point for the
collection iranian artists Munir faraman
faraman is best known for her work in
reverse glass painting and mirror mosaic
here she designed and made these gas
stoves for her New York apartment where
she lived there in exile for a number of
years before returning to Tehran Indian
artist Nalini mallanna's proto cinematic
exploration of Moving Image Traci
Moffitt's
cinematic photographs that knot at the
edge of ubiquitous media images of
migration displacement refuge and hope
Mona had to discover that uses the iron
rods that normally reinforce concrete
and in this case house fragile blown gas
sculpture so pure pitch a Cambodian
artist who uses bamboo so common in Asia
as building material
to make his sculpture that echoes the
architecture of his birthplace
the British architectural collective
Archy graham archive we acquired their
entire archive and they taught many Hong
Kong architects and have had an
influential role as architectural
theorists although they never realized a
build project as a collective they were
absolutely certain that they wanted to
place their archive with em+ as they
always felt that if they had realized
any architecture it would be the city of
Hong Kong the walking City with elevated
walkways and escalators connecting
significant parts of the city a snapshot
of collection development that was
undertaken in 2018 last year this is
establishment work this is what it means
to make a museum's collection just under
a thousand works but you can note 786
donations so our philanthropy base is
very important our collections are
already being known and loaned around
the world these are just nine examples
of recent loans but we have learnt over
76 exhibitions in 19 countries the
museum's role in society now as we build
our museum it's really important for me
to build an informed audience base in
Hong Kong and we have been actively
developing this since 2015 rerun us an
annual summer camp with a hundred
students with eight artists makers and
an intensive work on understanding what
it means to be artists designer
architects we have a rover a traveling
studio that goes out to the community to
schools and as public workshops we use
the city as our mobile exhibitions
we did this exhibition called neon
science where we crowd sourced from Hong
Kong has the best neon in Hong Kong we
we mapped it it's an online project and
then we had buses going out at night to
look at neon because neon is
disappearing and we are collecting that
neon neon is refuge in the museum one of
our first mobile exhibitions was on the
side of West Kowloon before it became a
building site and we did this exhibition
called
inflation which was looking at
contemporary temporary sculpture on the
park with inflatables highly it
generated a huge amount of debate and we
had over a hundred and forty thousand
people come in a very short space of six
weeks that it was on it was fantastic
while waiting for the museum's cinemas
to come online we work on a screenings
programme that are beginning to
cultivate our Moving Image audiences and
on the side of West Kowloon since 2060
we have a small M plus pavilion which is
our laboratory space and our next
exhibition which will be our tenth since
2016 will be the inaugural cig prize
Olli spent 20 years establishing the
contemporary Chinese art award in
Beijing but now with the in place museum
coming online and with his exhibit with
his collection in the museum we have
established the SiC prize like the
Turner Prize and we hope to make it one
of the most preeminent prizes for
contemporary Chinese artists now I am
very aware that to come here and speak
about a new museum development of the
scale and ambition of em+ in Hong Kong
now I must also acknowledge the social
unrest that is now our reality it is a
fact that the eyes of the world are
focused
the city and the West is looking east
this time to watch events as they unfold
across four months of both peaceful and
violent protests there is no question
there that we are living in deeply
unsettled times it is intense the
divisions in emerging and hardening in
the city make for an emotionally
exhausting reality over 85% of Hong Kong
does not own a car so the transport
arterioles the Metro the MTR our subway
system are vital avenues to move around
this highly efficient public transport
system is now being severely tested
through weekly confrontations and
disruptions that focus on the MTR and
for a while the airport
I have no crystal ball to be able to
suggest how this situation will resolve
we are living in a very divided city I
do think though that some of the works
in the em+ collections offer a chance to
reflect to pause and see what artists
have made sometimes in earlier years as
a means of providing insight into what
is happening today it is a sort of
creative tool a discursive
thought-provoking journey to now
currently on display at the em pub in
plus pavilion is an exhibition titled
five artists sites encountered and the
Hong Kong artists may phones 1989 work
she said why me is being screened May is
a founding member of video Tosh an
experimental artist on space established
to support Moving Image artists with a
forum to share ideas show works build
networks
both locally and globally slicing
historical footage from colonial era
Hong Kong with images of the 1967 riots
in Hong Kong the work explores the
ambiguity and uncertainties around
identity that the artist felt at the
time of making the work in 1989 30 years
ago when she made this Hong Kong was
preparing for handover and the push and
pull of that time feels strangely apt
thirty years later in 2019 we opened
this exhibition three days before the
protests began we had no idea that this
was coming and the exhibition was in
planning for eight months before Sampson
Young's we are the world since 2015
m+ has Co presented together with the
Hong Kong arts Development Council the
Hong Kong's pavilion in at the Venice
Biennale now in 2017 Sampson who comes
out of new music and composition was
commissioned by implants to make a new
work and he chose to approach the
pavilion via the cypher of songs for
disaster relief cogitating on the failed
utopian project of global disaster
relief and that hope to fund change
through releasing pop songs sung by the
likes of icons such as Bob Geldof in we
are the world young worked with the hong
kong federation of trade unions choir
and asked them to vocalize
Milius song it's a kind of unlearning of
what it means to sing it's a new music
technique where the voice whispers the
song you can barely hear we are the
world now looking at the world today it
immediately looking at the work today
and the world today it immediately
suggests an international context you
know we are the world and Hong Kong is
on a fault line one that feels intensely
local but as a cause beyond currently
showing at the Hong Kong Venice pavilion
again we co commissioned is the work of
Shirley's a stakeholders Hong Kong in
Venice her commissioned work negotiated
differences is a new work it's a
sculpture made of singular pieces of
turn wood each piece is unique often in
the shape of an everyday object a chair
leg a tenpin a baseball bat
a rolling pin candelabra each of these
turned wood sculptures is connected to
another using piping joints that have
been made with 3d printing using the
traditional Chinese furniture making
technique of joinery the sculpture uses
no nails pins or glue
rather the work is connected together
through balance a rhizomatic structure
that we use its way through the various
spaces of the Venice pavilion the
sculpture negotiated difference can
never be viewed in its entirety from a
single point of view you need to walk
through and around it to see it should
one section come on
done the work collapses and needs to be
reassembled and brought back into its
wholeness as balance it is this work
that you have seen the bringing together
of exceptional art architecture design
architect and moving image that makes m+
and our collective work in the museum so
important today now more than ever the
Civic functions of museums are needed
and in place will be the first global
modern and contemporary visual culture
museum based in Asia our equivalent
organisations in the world would be San
Francisco Museum of Modern Art or the
modern in New York
Santo Pompidou in Paris it is a place to
slow down to reflect to learn to be
challenged to enjoy to share together
together museums belong to people and it
is in these spaces that we are provided
with an affirmation of critical creative
expression of the work of artists
architects designers and makers they
provide the essential Internet
intellectual nourishment we need thank
you
[Applause]
so Frank asked is there a perspective to
art this uniquely Asian is there a
perspective to out that is huge
nucleation yes I think you know each of
us brings unique perspectives and Asia
has its own stories and it responds to
those locations and historical realities
that's why I began with ink ink is very
specific form in East Asia in particular
and has a deep history of working with
that material in its modern and
contemporary expression it has taken it
into a whole other space of abstraction
and abstraction that was not informed
particularly by Western canonical ideas
of abstraction so yes it does have
unique perspective and important unique
perspectives that we need to see so
Brian Eno's one of our board members and
participates a lot one of the points he
makes is art is in many respects about
our art or paint or s pay attention to
other artists from their own period and
orders that precede them and all the way
on back to probably cave art and so in a
sense I'm curious how much you think the
Asian artists are paying attention
mainly to other Asian artists we're
paying attention to some of the Western
canon of art where who are they sort of
drawing on and who are they basically
seeking you to surpass you know like I
said Asia is changing very fast very
rapidly and it's highly connected world
it's it's very international
world as well many Asian artists have
trained in other parts of the world in
other parts of Asia they go from some
parts of Asia they go to Russia to train
other parts of the world go to parts of
Asia go to the UK to train but we also
find now major schools in Asia and in
Hong Kong where students come from
intra-regional developments and
interests so this kind of flow of
information of ideas is now a fact of of
Asia today it's without question so
there isn't a single singular Asia as
it's many many different things many
histories many religions many languages
so it has a kind of diversity that you
see in Europe and you know Asia is half
the world's population is a huge place
and the way I'm assuming there's more
variety and variety of artistic
traditions well enormous variety in
artistic traditions that body is also
very nice to see is yes training happens
all over the world but also they're
looking into and back into history that
artisan are doing now is as important
and and
fascinating to watch which bits of
history people pick in Hong Kong
you mentioned 7.5 million people plus
many more than that coming in and out
there's assuming sort of a fair number
of artists working right there you
showing someone and work here are they
aware I mean you know when you're an
artist in New York you know all the
other artists in New York you're paying
very close attention to go to the
gallery showings and you walk your
studio so they don't steal your ideas
and all this definitely do the Hong Kong
artists have that sense of themselves as
a community very strong it's a very very
strong artists arts community design
community film community and developed
wonderful experimental spaces artists
wrong spaces as well so you have that
ecology building in Hong Kong but what's
missing is the big missing piece is the
museum the the big museums there are
civil service run museums in in Hong
Kong but most of those museums are
focusing on Chinese art and Chinese art
often with with great 19th century and
earlier collection sitting behind very
important to have those museums as well
but this is a first museum that'll be a
global institution that has that
cross-disciplinary collections that are
looking at the work made in our time of
course the other thing that I didn't
mention but I should say is and that you
mentioned in the beginning was how the
commercial muscle has grown you know
very rapidly in the last 15 years in
Hong Kong collectors and the art market
is enormous its second now behind New
York it's a very very serious collectors
market and that's a and they're looking
at contemporary art of course but also
why in coins historical Chinese all of
that is happening in Hong Kong because
it's it has a free port the tax there's
no tax on the movement of objects and
and as I said the disposable income now
of a substantial middle class in Asia is
looking to art and they are to nourish
their lives so are the customers of
those galleries mainland Chinese newly
come into wealth for South Asia people
from all over the world who is
fundamentally Asia but of course beyond
we find every March the Art Basel Hong
Kong is is the gathering of the art
world
clan we get many museums and they're
collected and collectors and patrons
coming but also huge numbers of mainland
Chinese collectors collectors from Japan
from South Korea from Indonesia and that
collector base is growing a very serious
game do they sell art as well or they
also do to the biggest you mean whether
the collectors are speculators I'm
starting to speculate afraid yes there
is some of course I mean a collector
wouldn't be a collector if they didn't
speculate and they always want the bar
game they want to get in early in the
market but the contemporary art market
is it's very hard to in come to
understand the rationale behind it two
weekends ago the big sales of sutherby
were happening in Hong Kong and over
hundred million US dollars worth of sale
happened there over those two days it's
phenomenal I can't resist asking a
little more on that it's one of the
things that sort of drives speculation
and are these superstars sort of artists
who become that's the first thing you
want to have that's what you see this is
the Picasso of the 21st century I'm
getting up early and stuff our
superstars emerging among the Asian
artists yes absolutely I mean some of
the biggest superstars of world art
international art today are Asian
artists many of them Chinese
contemporary artists but you know the
the auction record that was set two
weekends ago was by Japanese artists
Nara and he's painting went for
something like 35 million us a lot of
money but yes there are there are many
many Asian artists that are now
superstars and many of them with studios
in in the US as well like Thai food
Cheung in New York it's a megastar and
need to know my way way darlin
absolutely all of those artists yeah so
in the one hand you've got the sort of
the top of the investment level
perspective and artists incredibly
expensive and rather magnificent Museum
going in I was a artist in Laura side of
New York back in the day and the people
I was named with with of course the
Loring site because that's where it was
cheap to live and everything was on the
just getting by and so there I assumed
that square with many young ambitious
artists in Hong Kong and elsewhere and
then that overlaps into innocence hard
his ours rebellion
anyway you're always rebellion against
the standard our code before your
rebellion against the man who or that
you know
institution is seen as and protesters
that you know in the United States are
in off the protesters in Hong Kong right
now who seem to have more creative
techniques and more creative artistry in
a way in in their protest that's pretty
interesting bottom-up kind of creativity
what's your perspective on that it's
very interesting to watch the the visual
language that's being applied now in in
Hong Kong primarily of course it's a
tool for communication it is nothing to
do with museum per se but as a museum we
are very interested in that as a visual
culture form the protesters use the this
emblem to describe themselves there they
talk them about themselves as being like
water so they will flow their
free-flowing their leaderless their
spontaneous and so a lot of the material
that's been that's taking place in terms
of protest is digital and it's a digital
form as a communication tool and and all
of it is an author that this at this
point because they do not want to have a
single author it's not in their interest
to do so
our teams are very interested where our
documenting we have archives and so we
can document we are doing that and
researching how or when and if you are
interested
it has to go through the usual museum
mechanism and process of thinking and
looking and seeking rights who owns
these things and perhaps they are not to
be owned and that's fine
but they need exist in other kinds of
ways so it's a very very interesting
phenomena this time unlike so much much
earlier periods of protest art which had
very clear activist expressions you know
like you couldn't win in the u.s. there
are the guerrilla girls and their whole
portfolios of prints and so on that are
very clearly authored and therefore
distribution this is a very different
mechanism that that's taking place in
Hong Kong and the digital tool is
phenomenal so the digital tools
phenomenal and getting more so how are
you Museum dealing with digital is it
everything at this point how does that
play out no it's not everything we think
we think very carefully about digital we
have redid ties the collection as do
most museums and we are in the process
of digitizing it would be available
online yeah yeah we already have five
thousand objects online but we are do
everywhere does anybody for you M plus M
plus you just put a selection and it
just comes straight up yeah what do you
recommend they start wherever the icon
lands because you know the the it's a
rhizomatic digital world and those who
are interested in the digital will find
their way
very very easily but we do everything in
two languages in Chinese and in English
so everything has to be translated
properly and understood in both
languages we are also looking at digital
commissioning for us we were we work
with living living artists so
commissioning is a very important part
of what we do what I should have meant
and I realized I didn't show you was
that a design of the museum has the
tower and you saw in the video Lin
talking about the the facade of in plus
tower the facade is actually embedded
with LED and it's a screen it's a it's a
gigantic screen 60 meters high by a
hundred and ten meters across and and
Hong Kong of course has a lot of lights
and a lot of commercial digital screens
as part of its landscape night scape and
we will add to that with our digital
screen for artists commissions so that's
another form of digital experience and
and we would like that Digital is going
to be an interactive one because so many
people have used interactive
methodologies on their on their phones
on their smartphones and so the first
commissions will in fact involve that
kind of dialogue with our audiences we
do we digitize content in the sense that
we work with all artists talks and so on
and have them online and we'll build an
archive of that material but we're also
collecting digital art so young Han
Chang Heavy Industries is a very good
example that took you know it was I
remember when we announced that
acquisition people were you know the
media were very fascinated
but confused I said but it's already
available online why would you acquire
you know what is this and what and we
had to explain that a certain number of
works are available online by young hmm
every interest is but it's a whole lot
of work that they've done that isn't
available that they want to have the
museum have acquire for posterity's sake
so we've done that and their catalog
into the future because the digital
world is also changing so fast museum
will become Refuge as well for that
change just just like 35 mil and 16 mil
film is now today it's it's you know
it's really museums that show those
forms of early Moving Image yeah 3d
cinema theaters m+ what's what's your
approach on collecting film collecting
film is complex because film is a
licensed media and so we need to work
with licensing as a way of managing film
film well of course we will screen but
we are looking and exploring the idea of
restoration which is very complex idea
but you know many museums undertaking
especially when we know that if we don't
restore we will lose that material and
we cannot afford to lose it but few film
is the medium of our time as is st.lucia
whereas no paintings and sculptures come
from much earlier times she mentioned
commissioning for like give it a little
bit more of a picture the you're facing
postcard Island Hong Kong yeah yeah Hong
Kong is facing you so you've got this
display side of the building how big
this is green sixty metres high by a
hundred and ten meters close uh-huh
which I guess from Long Island will be
it's actually it'll it'll look like a
huge high-definition screen from Hong
Kong Island but it's actually very
interesting screen it's a lenticular
screen because the podium is a public
space for people to go and gather around
it's a garden and if you're on the
podium and you look up it's a sharp
angle you can see an image in a high
definition from that angle as well so
theoretically we should be able to do
two different images one for those
sitting on the podium and the others
across on Hong Kong Island but we are
yet to find out if that is the case yeah
so at least one country two systems
[Laughter]
for other kinds of commissioning they
could be doing we will Commission for
the institution's collections as well
we've already begun because the spaces
that Hertzog anywhere on earth designed
for us encourage that kind of work you
know if some museum spaces are very
large for us an empress and they need
site-specific work to enliven and and
give a different perspective on to space
so we will use commissioning to manage
that is where Australia fits into this
because your your professional past much
of it is in Australian see a little bit
about that sequence for you it's a very
interesting history for me because I
spent 20 years in the Queen's an art
gallery in Brisbane and when I joined in
the early 90s it was very small you know
I'm like a regional gallery and it had
no a fine collection of Australian art
but nothing of significance and the then
director dark hole decided that he would
establish a project called the
asia-pacific triennial of Contemporary
Art and the first one was in 93 and I
joined then and we and I was able to
persuade him to start collecting and we
worked with advisors and we built inside
the Brisbane museum a curatorial
expertise and we began acquiring Asian
Contemporary Arts in the early 90s so we
were very
early to begin that collection
development and it was frankly a blank
page when it came to Western
institutions but I was always asked why
is Australia doing this at that time and
Australia was doing this I would always
answer because it is about our
neighborhood and our demography it's a
full of migrant people and many migrants
from Vietnam from China from India from
Korea it's it's a Sri Lanka Sri Lankan
bomb the dyers press in in Australia
very significant part of community and
and to have coherent communities you
have to have diverse points of view and
it was very forward-thinking at that
time for Doug to be able to persuade
government to fund what was then a
unknown project of what is contemporary
Asian Pacific ours in the 90s LED late
80s beginning that research and it led
to the formation of a very important
collection that I drove and I have
always advocated for the importance of
contemporary Asian Pacific work that
work of 20 years meant also in Brisbane
we built we expanded the museum and
built a second museum a second site
because of the collections of content
creation art which were often monumental
in scale and needed space and then I
joined the arguably South Wales to work
on the expansion in Sydney of that state
institution working with the Japanese
architects Anna and after four years of
working within Sydney
three and a half years I was I couldn't
resist the would resist Hong Kong and m+
because it had felt for me my life's
journey was always advocating for the
importance of these other art histories
that the canons needed to be expanded so
Hong Kong felt like the perfect place to
do just that so it seems like Australia
during a couple decades you were in the
thick of there was kind of shifting its
thinking in its activities from seeing
itself as a branch of the British Empire
to being a basically an Asian country
country in Asia and off Asia increasing
is that yeah no it's absolutely it's a
it's a very very good observation
because it it is also about the you know
who who am i we these questions were
very important questions and I think
there are important questions wherever
you are and it's important to look
inside your community as much as outside
and the and your neighborhood and
Australia is in that neighborhood and
that relationship to Britain were
severed you know and yes there was a lot
of looking back to the motherland as it
were but that motherland was drifting
further and further away and other lands
were coming much closer an important
histories including indigenous
Aboriginal histories in Australia were
very important advocacy role in terms of
opening up that looking and and that
happened in the 70s in Australia that
prominent voice of
version of Australia being also inside
museum there is contemporary Aboriginal
very soon
very strong very very vital strong part
of all museums in in Australia but also
cultural identity some of that show up
in yes in fact one of the works I just
showed Tracy Moffitt is an indigenous
Australian artist and she's very
interested in those relationships of
migration and belonging so I guess I'm
wondering how far this Asia region
you get Polynesian are Maori are and
then how far but it really to all be in
the sense how far west as they should go
on the perspective yeah for us
definitions are West Asia which is the
you know the Middle East we have Iranian
artists as part of our collection but
Australia New Zealand they're part of
the Pacific really and they are you know
oh Australia's on the kind of fulcrum of
Pacific and Asia both function in a both
feature in a lot of the work done in
Australia but it's it's it's a fluid
space and in the end you look for works
that speak to the collections that
you're building it and that's why that
international perspective the global
world of the collections that I showed
give you an idea of the attitude and and
how we approach that that kind of
collection interest but I think it's
very important that you're alive to the
world and it doesn't mean that
exhibitions can't happen from
parts of you know other parts of the
world whether it's New Zealand or Africa
what's the sort of mechanism of
collection mechanism of selecting you
were working in Australia were you
basically going to artists with your
studios or the galleries your where are
you going to plan to you and who else is
fighting on this are yes curators it's
this kind of fundamental research
curatorial work that takes place and
travel and going and visiting and seeing
is very important part of that work and
asia-pacific trial in Brisbane gave us
that three year beats which meant you
had a very nice rhythm to the research
in in Hong Kong of course as soon as you
leave Hong Kong you're travelling even
on the 15-minute express train
interchange in that is travel and Hong
Kong travels all the time people are
always traveling it's kind of in the DNA
of Hong Kong and and travel is also
traveling other people travel to Hong
Kong that's exchange that cosmopolitan
energy is a very important part of Hong
Kong's identity so we are always alert
and alive to that and people come all
the time to speak to to go and see be to
see each other to network then I was on
call in this respect and relations our
way to other cities like Singapore
Shanghai or Beijing or whatever or
cities in India City to see on cities
cities where a lot of the action is and
zatia anyway and and how does that play
out for you guys
you know cities it's it's an interesting
question because the you know for vast
parts of Asia urbanization is a is a
huge energy driver and focus but also
large parts of Asia are rural still and
you know you have many many people
living outside the city and in many ways
say in terms of architecture the most
innovative architecture is taking place
outside cities because that's where the
experiment can take place in its most
lively form and especially in mainland
China where some of the second-tier
cities which are still vast I might add
do you know are really interested in
sustainability for example and they'll
look at solar energy as powering those
cities it's very very interesting to see
but urbanization is very easy to
understand and see within Asia because
they are they're such large you know the
cities are enormous but the rural world
is as important to think about in Asia
Vincent yes what mechanisms are in place
to counter the influence of the
government on the curation process it's
important artists often politically
tricky yeah there's a very good question
it's a very good question
the structure the governance structures
for implants based on global museum
based practice so we have our own board
and on our board collectors
you know senior stakeholders in Hong
Kong who are understanding what it means
to make a museum the Kowloon West
Kowloon district has a board as well
because it's a it's a large undertaking
know and up until two years ago the
chair of the West Kowloon district board
was always the chief secretary of Hong
Kong which is the second in charge of
the city so it was completely linked to
government but when the current chief
executive was chief secretary and was
the board chair of his cologne district
authority she visited many museums
including here in San Francisco mama and
and part of the education process for
her was that she understood that it was
actually much better not to have that
direct relationship with government for
both sides for both of us and when she
became chief executive she she didn't
the the chair of West Kowloon board no
longer became was the chief secretary
but she appointed Henry Tang who has who
knows politics very well because he was
in politics but is no longer and that
immediately changed the relationship to
content and and it's very important for
in plus that we have an independent
curatorial practice and that our
integrity in fact lies in that ability
to make those decisions so the
governance helps and government
governance is now very good for Empress
and West Kowloon but I think the other
part of the work in front is to ensure
that we can
you to practice with courage well Krieg
is very useful at a time of what looks
like serious transition Hong Kong you'll
be playing out these relationships
clearly with governance systems they
keep changing for a while and sounds
like when can we come visit well the
museum is will have our construction
will be completed by March next year and
it's a very large museum sixty-five
thousand square meters of construction
and as soon as we've got our our
licenses our occupation permits which
should happen by April next year between
nine to twelve months we will be ready
for the public we have storage in seven
different parts of the world right now
so we need to gather the collections and
prepare for public so when you try to
open serve the entire museum all at once
or by stages we want to end open the end
time in solid ones that strong soil 2021
perhaps
you know we do very there's an
incredible energy inside the city and I
remember doing a project in Brisbane
where I invited a group of artists from
what was called a long march project in
Beijing and we were building our
expansion for Queens an art gallery at
the time and their proposal was you're
taking too long let me bring the workers
and you build your museum in half the
time the office era but I mean it feels
like that in Hong Kong when you look at
this the scale of the empress building
and how fast it's it's grown it was we
broke earth in 2013 and you know we'll
be prepared to open within 13 14 15 16
17 18 19
seven years you know and that's Hertzog
and amaura always say this is their
fastest museum building project that
they have ever undertaken and they have
undertaken some pretty big ones
including the DeYoung here so for them
they feel that this is for the scale and
and the structural engineering that had
to take place to make it plus come up
out of the ground this has been an
incredibly fast architectural journey
but at the same time as you saw from the
construction workers there is you know
inside interesting we've got to get this
right art concrete we have to make it
good so it is fast fast and it looks
very good I can't wait to see it
[Applause]
[Music]